خلال الاشتباكات الحاليه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع المطارات
كانت محورا رئيسيا تدور فيها وحولها
المعارك لما لها من اهميه استراتيجيه
فمطار العاصمه هو الاكبر في السودان انشئ
عام
1947 ومر بعمليات التوسعه واعاده تاهيل
حتى اصبح مركزا بنسبه 95% من حركه الطيران
الخارجيه وهناك مطار الابيض يقع في
المدينه التي تحمل ذات الاسم غرب الخرطوم
وهو نقطه وصل بين العاصمه ومعظم مناطق
دارفور كما انه مركز لقوات حفظ السلام
الامميه التي تراقب الحدود بين السودان
ودوله جنوب السودان اخيرا مطار مروي يقع
في الولايه الشماليه وتتداخل فيه الاهميه
الاقتصاديه بالعسكريه هذا المطار كان من
المشاريع المصاحبه لانشاء خزان او سد مروي
الكهرومائي كما انه يحتوي على قاعده جويه
عسكريه